okay
hello everyone we are looking at
biosequences and um
uh that are being made ready for the
next version of language
so first thing we have is a page about
bio
biological sequences by molecule
biomolecular how about biomolecular
sequences
that sounds that definitely sounds
better
biomolecule by the way i hope i don't
have to update these pages today because
i they will have been updated overnight
or is that sufficient
i think john made various changes today
and let's not use this page let's
let's do an update first so we don't
overwrite those changes
and then okay so biomolecular sequence
computation biomolecular sequence
computation something like that
that sounds good okay then i'm gonna
leave you to change the
the actual title of the page and so on
and um
but let's let's go ahead and um
pages boy lots of
have you been adjusting all these things
like string of us and so on have you
been adding links in those
in those pages is that what's been going
on there that's right
yes okay
okay biomolecular
sequence computation
singular plural
biomolecular sequences
that's okay biomolecule sequence is
computation
okay so this is
well then you say computation down here
so that won't work will it
okay do we want to just keep it generic
and have biomolecular sequences
full stop
okay so i'm going to leave you to change
all these things okay
sequence representation okay so now
should i be looking at these pages like
biosequence and so on
yes can we be specific what okay
so then biosequence evaluates
what
it's similar to molecules and other
functions
because we have various input forms so
it canonicalizes
okay obviously these are these are this
this is not the right format here but
you'll deal with that right
did you understand that's not the right
the point
yeah same with these things here
okay you know i don't know how many
times i have to explain this
the right hand side here needs to be
less than one line long not multiple
sentences
come on guys figure out how to do it
please
so now i mean just don't do this you
know i wish people would just not do
this and not get it wrong
you put a separate note afterwards that
says that
you know we had this style that we've
developed over years
and please let's not break it for this
particular case
yep
okay what are the notable things that
have changed since last time and is this
mostly the approved design from last
time or not
yeah the design is approved it's the
just the documentation
okay so are you asking me to write the
documentation or what what's the issue
no trust canada giving your kid for on
futurising
okay all right and i i mean there's a
little bit of discussion about the
string pages
which is why jeremy and i are here okay
well let's look at a typical string page
like string reverse
right so question one is does this
really want to be
in the main usage or does it want to be
a note
in the uh you know in the notes
right i think it should be in the notes
okay i think it should be in the notes
just like we say that
you know something which operates on a
list we also say also operates on sparse
arrays and so on
yep i think it should be that type of
note
okay i can i can i can i can point them
to models
and then you know some of the pages like
string match queue
and string take i think have an
additional note about
sort of special behavior that you may
want to
review regular constraints
started m
so string take of 10 million will still
work even a little tiny
um what they call plasmid thingy is that
right
well i i guess that's
well i guess that's a question for john
and and something i i don't quite know
the answer to
i mean will this ever give a longer
answer than what's there
like if you do let's try to
i'd say biosequence how do i make a
circular dna string
there's no autocomplete here that should
be fixed
see that yeah i can teach them how to do
that
why is this taking a long time
that's just loading it once it should be
faster after that
okay so that will do the expected thing
okay
now if we say strength take percent 151
comma 20.
oh splatteroo
that's interesting
uh wasn't this not the case john where
we discussed with isabel
that we decided you can't read multiple
times around because this is what never
happens in biology
that's right yeah this is only for the
case where you reverse eight and five
say for example
i mean it's it's expression is it the
biological operational is a mathematical
operation
yeah okay that's clearly a bad error
message
right you understand yes yes we
understand this one yes
okay now the question is okay this
question of whether you read multiple
times around the circle
i i don't know why a ribosome can't just
spend its time
you know hanging out in like a like a
you know one of those um
hamster wheels you know why can't it
just go around the hamster wheel many
times
maybe it can but according to isabel who
is a worked at this field she said this
is not how
ac ribosomes read
humph okay well more than i know um all
right
right to discuss this right and of
course i mean the
the relevance of this note is if you
change that nine to an
eight so you do eight five rather than
right what case thanks
okay but i don't understand that case
wouldn't wouldn't that work
i mean in other words if i just take an
ordinary string
that'll give you an empty list or
complain
right unless you gave a negative step
i see so this is reverse reading this is
a string take reverse
reading why doesn't it work on a linear
dna sequence
right it's not reversing it it's
starting it's starting at
eight which is the last one and then
continuing forward and wrapping around
i see i see so it won't take
let you take something that's longer
than the whole circle
but you can't start anywhere on the
circle and end anywhere else on the
circle
which is not something you can do with
normal strings because they're not
circular
seems okay to me i don't think we're
going to get ourselves in trouble with
that
okay all right what was the other case
string match queue
yep
yeah i think that's the right thing to
do for biosequences with the patterns
put that make the patterns include the
biological
know wild cards
otherwise it would be useful yeah right
yeah seems right to me okay i don't
think the behavior is controversial it's
just
you know making sure that you're okay
with this description of it
and the other question was do you want
the free table here in this function or
is it okay you have to put a table
somewhere
how big is the table
where is the table it's on it's that big
t
it's the first table which you said you
wasn't formatted correctly in
biosequence
this one here yes and then but that's
not defining
it well it's a it's a
slight it's a slightly proper subset of
that
right so so this is built into the
uh sequence type
entity type and there's documentation of
it on that page
okay no not good enough you need to have
it
you need to have it here you need to
start okay
this is super confusing so what you
should say here
is you know the first thing you should
say
to not confuse somebody like me okay is
that dna
the literals are agct
that's correct isn't it right similarly
for rna with the you you know
agut whatever to t no agctu
right and and then give the literals for
the peptide
and then say the following
uh wild card degenerate or something
ones are also supported and then i would
give the table which isn't terribly hard
i mean just as
each one you know n is all of them et
cetera et cetera
the forms for constructing it
what that's incomprehensible
so this is a case so if you say you want
a
uh a five-term dna sequence i'm aware
i'm aware of what it is i'm aware of
what it is and you can say that in a
note somewhere but that's not a table
you should give a table
you should give a table of the
non-degenerate cases you should give a
table of degenerate cases
this is a footnote somewhere i mean this
is uh
what's an example of where you can
generate that
that's yeah biosequence dna five
was that documented that's an example
listen guys how many times do i have to
say this examples
are not documentation okay
if there is a form of biosequence which
what has
a number in it you must document it at
the top here do you know
the second one oh yeah that's sorry i'm
sending to the question
this is the second one okay
i would call that comma n to make it
less obscure in that in that actual
usage
you got it yeah and i would just say
quotes the sequence if that's a string
just say quotes the string you see what
i'm saying yeah
yeah i mean i i i guess uh i'd been
focusing on the string
pages i i would have caught this and
pointed out that
yes this is not keeping in our style um
i mean i don't think we would use string
i think we would use
like stir or sack uh
like that it's fine yeah and this type
or is a string or not
no it can be the entity okay fine
okay chem list should show a list of
those molecules
or what molecules are entities okay well
so i think you should say chem one
chem two etc
the only reason not to i mean it just
that way somebody who glances at this
can see what's going on
that makes sense yeah that's great
okay
most implied by the sequence
what the heck is that come on what does
that even mean
it that given the letters you can in
most cases
refer information so infers
attempts to infer the type from the
sequence right
right is what what that should say
and it should be down at the second
element here this is the the second one
here
should be um
this should be there really
it's a very common case it's going to be
the most common case people type in
you think so they will not say i think
that it's just a friendliness
if they type a biosequence they're going
to just type agct whatever it is
okay and i would put the go ahead yeah i
i think i agree that it's probably
more common well i guess it depends on
whether you're an expert or not but i
think
it's probably more common at least for
non-experts to
just type in the one argument form there
than to type in a type and a
and a length yeah it's very obscure the
length stuff
should go away at the end in my view
and i think those those things with
genes and proteins
i don't know why you say entity i i
would say
oh that is a horrible thing there okay
um
uh you know infers the type
represents a biological sequence
that is no good biological sequence just
doesn't cut it
um i thought we changed all biologically
biomolecules already
earlier discussion okay right well i
i guess that raises a question of should
this still be called biosequence
absolutely absolutely
it's fine it's a good shortening
okay just like geo is called geo
even though we know it's sort of
geographic position geo position
but but stephen now i think we are
getting full the first one
is a representation the second one is
not a representation it evaluates
okay okay
and so this one we say infers the type
from the content
of the seek of the string of the
sequence
from the uh elements that appear in the
sequence
sequence
should we not use letters because
elements is another
technical term all right fine from the
sequence
something like that and then what i
would say here
is
biosequence of
um ant
um
gives the bio
associated with
specified with the entity
and um
gene protein gene or protein
entity is that are those the only cases
oh no
okay i can change that one those are not
the only cases
um and then you should say what you know
how the entity is specified later
in the notes right right and
i'm not sure we need the what's
currently i think it's the fourth one
the biosequence of type
i mean that to me seems like it could be
a note how how often
are you just going to create an
arbitrary one letter
yeah i agree i think the next thing we
should give here
is the chemicals
and i think we should do that and we can
yes we don't forget the syntax
processing stuff but i mean that one
well we'll have it from biosequence of
end right so there's already a
documented one argument form
fair enough although but we need to make
sure the auto completes work correctly
for that type thing
okay yeah that's i mean that is a weird
case i agree i think that's a weird case
i don't
i'm not even certain that i support that
case
um okay let's take a look at what it's
doing here all right
so circular dna or dna
i think god's sake why don't you say dna
or circular dna
i mean you know dna is much more common
right
why isn't there circular rna as well
there generally isn't circular rna
it generally doesn't exist okay
okay so let's get in that order right
um
the caption above the sequence then
formatted output
what's all this about this is for
extending
uh bios if you make your own ones
we had discussions in this one meeting
um okay you've got to reduce these caps
yes
absolutely right and um
okay so
no no that's a very obscure thing to say
what you've got to say is something like
if um the standard form
is the standard form for biosequence is
type comma sequence is that right yeah
or the canonical form maybe uncle form
for biosequence
just kind of to be self-consistent we
used exactly the form
for molecule that you fought a year ago
well we had exactly this velvet okay all
right okay fine
well then then yeah then we should do
whatever molecule does
should we look up molecule yeah
okay molecule blah blah blah that's
pretty clear actually
right i think uh i i think where they
went wrong is they
didn't uh right they they left out the
the bracket dot dot dot which made it
sound quite different from what it was
trying to say
i see okay
i don't know how to fix that but you
guys could do that
like we need if possible if you put in
junk then it cannot evaluate properly
and also you need to you need to give
yeah the quotes scq now i don't know
whether the
dot dot is needed is it is
okay let's let's make sure we see all
the other ones where
we need to see here so this
so i is something like sequence
alignment just says
well right now it has a futurized usage
but i think we should follow what we did
with
i know this one maybe has a slightly i
think this one is worth worth putting
the biosequence up there
this biosequence is a really common case
for sequence alignment right
so i would put it there i would
similarly put it
in the case i would not put it for
hamming distance because i
don't wheel
i don't know it's probably not harmless
for having distance what do you think
that
what do you think for these distances i
would think for this one's yes
okay so so by the way on the pages for
distance
measures we should list some we should
mention something about biosequences on
those pages
you mean the guide pages yes about
sequences
okay about about distances rather
um
okay let's take a look here
biosequence convert
that is a very strange name
biosequence convert i mean does it
usually produce
one sequence
depends if you have white coats okay you
know what
this is a really misleading thing to say
here just say
it converts the biological sequence does
it always produce a list
yes
is that a good idea
yeah i i didn't like it either but i
didn't have a better idea because we
cannot have different arguments
structured to get different result type
because it only depends on the presence
of white cards
i mean we could have a third argument
all and otherwise give only one but this
seemed a little bit strange to me also
it's strange
well hold on a second is it strange how
do people how will people use this
they have a piece of dna want to
translate it exactly
and depending on the quality of their
pcr they get it with all without
white cards i'm confused by something
why are we not translating wild cards
i mean okay but so why is this exploding
things those are two different
operations
in other words if you have an n there
okay if i have a dna with an n why
doesn't that just turn into an
rna with an n
or in the case of yeah transcribe it
does
yeah that in that case they map one to
one it's for peptides
the wild cards and the the trend
the uh okay not a good answer because
transcribe what's the difference okay we
got three things convert transcribe
translate
those are completely confusing here
right
you got to do better
that's [ __ ] i'm sorry sequence
recognition is not what this
is okay sequence recognition is what you
know some molecule does when it's doing
something
right no yeah the name is not good
i mean transcribe and translate i think
are the terms used in the literature
i'm well aware but we got to explain
here rather than just saying
i mean no no that's not what this does
right so well because it converts it to
a list of sequences
right resolving all but it doesn't say
to a sequence i i don't care
it's misleading okay so let's go through
what what these
okay yeah and most of the time is it
transcribe and translate that people are
going to use
if they translate it's going to be much
more frequent
than what then transcribe
okay why isn't it at the top here
i think they were being alphabetical uh
well that was a dumb idea yes um
right so then tell me what is
biosequence convert and how is it
different from both translate and
transcribe because
i think i understand what those do
poorly but i have some understanding of
what those are
sorry do i want to say inverse or
reverse because these aren't does this
operation have an inverse
reverse done reverse is probably better
okay so this was a bad thinking piece of
bad thinking here i might say so
okay so now this complement thing is
also
very very very common operation
of a dna sequence
a
t c to g right that's what we're talking
about isn't that right
okay the next thing we want to do is we
want to say string reverse because
that's the next thing people want to do
right
i would think but do you really want to
but but string operations with these
other ones yeah but
it doesn't fit in this group no it
doesn't
okay all right fine um
but this is completely wrong string
reverse is by far the most important up
well
yeah okay all right
okay okay no no we're going to put
reverse complement in here because
that's another thing people
do
reverse and complement a dna sequence
okay now
right so what is this thing actually
doing that's different
from any of the four previous guys
it explodes wild cards
that's what it does is that true
it does it it also converts to molecule
it supersedes it does more than the
earlier ones
all right so but it does does it also do
the things like
does it also translate and transcribe uh
if you give it the right
second argument that's right between
between
biomolecular types
with resolution
um
yeah just by the way i'd like to put
this one above
like to put the rna above the peptide
one even though it's it's just
logically general conversion but go
ahead
i i'm going to i mean
maybe this doesn't make biological sense
but from a language design point of view
don't we need a biosequence expand that
expands the wild cards and then this
convert thing can just do
you know one thing which is converting
well i would think so yeah i mean i
think that would be better because the
convert
what does the convert do
translate could perfectly well have a
destination that is a molecule yes
so i thought translation was a specific
uh like the
it is but how do you get to a molecule
with convert how does convert
and by the way it doesn't even document
it it's not even documented
where is it even documented what it does
where is it documented where's the list
of what this possible types are
john did we have such a such a table i
don't think we ever did
no okay what are the possible types
there's dna rna
peptide a molecule and
if you don't give a type it it just does
the expansion okay so
just explain to me can it be circular
dna
not currently okay but that's something
we could imagine but but okay
so molecule is an alternative to peptide
right by the way are we really calling
it peptide not protein
i guess we discussed this the last time
and we came to the conclusion peptide
okay all right fine okay but but so
molecule
is a translation is a form of
translation right
if you say convert dna to
molecule you end up with a molecule of
the dna
if you say convert biosequence convert
and you have a peptide then it gives the
molecule of the peptide
what biosequence converts okay what
destination type gives the molecule of
peptide molecule
okay so if you have a peptide you get a
peptide molecule if you have a dna you
get a dna molecule i don't understand
why we're not just using you wrap
molecule around the biosequence you get
the frigging molecule
that there was an earlier design for
that we could we could do that i think
that's what we should do
so if that's the k um aside from
uh the molecule uh having transcription
and translation handled by their own is
there
um let's see is the the main
point of the biosequence convert to the
expanding the wildcat
well we should change its name it should
be called biosequence expand
then we should have two functions one
that just expands and keeps the type
and then we independently convert the
types
but we've got a function that converts
the types it's biosequence translate
but it doesn't make all possible causes
but
which one doesn't translate and then
expand which one doesn't it make
but yeah translate only makes peptides
it's biological translation
it's not translated in the language
sense okay which ones
do we need what are all the crosses
let's go through those please
what are they i mean i you've just told
me that there is
dna to rna dna to rna
okay that is otherwise known as
transcribe isn't it dna to rna is
transcribed
i think you're not okay go ahead you
want rna to peptides
okay and that's translate
and we want sometimes peptide to rnase
that's translated just i'm reading the
documentation
okay and what's right so what other
possibilities are there that molecule
but that's been covered because it's
either biosequence of molecule a
molecule a biosequence
but but
[Music]
john what are all the implemented cases
i mean this is
probably thought out that okay we've got
all the cases you've got dna rna
peptides
and molecules okay and you've also got
circular dna
those are the only cases that i know of
here
that's right okay so we've covered all
the cases so
convert does nothing except wild card
expansion so it should have the name
expand
okay right and then it makes perfect
sense for it to return a singleton list
if there are no wild cards
exactly right exactly
translate we'll do the inverse
listen guys the problem is that there
are multiple inverse translations
correct
exactly that's right from what to what
from peptide to dna
and of course with white cards also in
the other direction okay i understand
peptide to dna okay so let's be very
careful this
says peptides or the reverse so what
does biosequence translate do
when you go peptides to dna
what does it do right now it will give
you a list
of okay what does it do for a single
thin one
what does it do for a single one does
biosequence translate always give a list
it always does yeah well then we've
already solved the problem
from going from peptides to our dna it
gives a list
but going from dna to peptides it does
not give a list is that correct
currently it always gives a list okay
that's wrong
that's wrong so let's not do that
okay in the case where it's going in the
rather obscure case and
okay so what do you want to do if if a
white card is inside
don't expand it wild cards go to wild
cards
in translate do not expand the wild gods
just
translate them wild card to wild god
there's no i don't think that is
possible yeah
the peptide wild card space doesn't
cover
the full specificity of combinations
it's it's more limited
well worst case says you go to an n in
the peptide
okay or an x yeah we can do that
but now okay this is really muddled
so there is a very useful operation
which is the pure expand
which we understand which which resolves
wildcard
cards exp oh shoot
definitely not what i want um
expand make a
well really it's more like biosequence
list isn't it
um
yeah biosequence instances is the right
one
that's the right thing
we have entity list so i think
this should be biosequence list
and we don't don't think so because that
list is more from a class
exactly there's a named class that i
feel like this one is different
give a list of instances
of of um in which wild cards
are resolved
um what is this really this is for
give i mean this
give a list of random instances
consistent give a list
of random instances
instantiations no because we just say
instances
i don't think it should it is all it
should be a two argument function then
this
the second one how many okay
because it might be astronomically big
okay
um give a list of random instances
of wild card resolution or something
we have a bunch of comments on our live
stream here
um i'm watching the clock and i know you
have to leave michael
um and uh so look look
we have any way to make some changes
before you you propose now some bigger
changes
right well let's just have a quick look
for other stuff here i mean i
that's mostly it okay biosequence modify
i just want to look at that
and the translate you're going to have
to do that ending
you know you understand what i'm saying
right right what is this this please
please michael
just look at these pieces of
documentation these don't follow
yeah uh i mean i don't know what all
this is
what is this examples it's not
but this isn't this is this yeah this is
not how you write documentation
okay yeah i don't even know what this is
with the space in it
vertebrate diet where is this this is
entities genetic translation table
is an entity type right that's right
okay so if i say entity list
genetic translation table
okay why are those capital letters
is that our standard thing to do in this
case
did you understand what i'm asking and
if i
say here standard name that's the
do we have a standard name or i like an
article name
thank you
really right well the canonical name is
right is always unique yes
but but why aren't we giving these
canonical names look
how many translation tables do we have
okay until we discover
life on europa or something we don't
have a lot of
translation tables
no are there not many john
there's a lot more than one would think
given all the archaic ones
okay is this the number of them is this
all the translation tables yes or no
this this is um
this is not probably not all of them
these are all only the ones that are
really
currently categorized okay fine
fine you know one that disappeared in
the pre-cambrian period and we barely
know about it we're not going to worry
about for this moment
okay let me tell you what you should do
okay first point
you need canonical names that do not
have extra crud in them
right there's no reason to have extra
crud in these names they're a small
number of names
then what you should do is in
i mean
you know you should let people put in
what is the standard one what what are
we i mean
the canonical name is unique and decided
by alpha i mean i don't think
i know but these guys these guys are
making these up so they can they can do
it right here they do not need to have
extra crud in these names
okay so which one are we vertebrate
nuclear
how can there be the invertebrates the
eukaryotes
isn't it am i crazy isn't it don't all
eukaryotes have the same
but eukaryotes are much beyond
vertebrates
it's true that that's that's the match
the the
our uh mitochondrial uh
uh i know my front here are different
right i know the mitochondria are
different
but this is crazy okay i'm sorry this is
crazy
look isn't it the case that all
eukaryotes or prokaryotes have and
that's what people learn in elementary
biology right
eukaryotes have one form prokaryotes of
one form am i right am i not right
i do not know i'm not sure i understand
the question
i'm complaining this is complete
nonsense it's not just vertebrates
you take your average you know amoeba
no bad example you take your average um
uh you know random worm
okay see an enemy okay you see an enemy
has the same
freaking translation table that we do
right and the sea an enemy is not a
vertebrate
overall i'm i'm with you take the
broadest possible coverage
instead of trying to match with the
mitochondrial name
i can do absolutely yes do that okay
and and then
okay so i mean doesn't the cnn does the
sea and enemies mitochondrion
have a different translation table than
ours
it it might i think it i think it might
yeah i'm
off hand i i don't know but i'd have to
i'd
okay i'd have to ali on our live stream
is saying that i'm wrong
so i'd like to know what i'm wrong about
um
so seeing enemies apparently there's an
invertebrate mitochondrial and a
vertebrate one
and they're different okay
but okay let's let's do a little bit of
biology
work here ask ask other people and let's
get
the most important thing is that if
there is a standard one for eukaryotes a
standard one for prokaryotes
that's kind of what people are going to
know i mean
let me look this up
okay we make some changes and come back
well okay okay but
michael i know you have to go so yep so
list of genetic codes
like
okay so this is interesting what
wikipedia does
for example okay which is not completely
stupid the standard code
that's not a completely stupid way to do
it i agree
we had that at one time what's what
switched back to that
i mean it's a little bit you know us
centric but you know
that's um
nature of the business
i think it requires a little bit more
thought okay but but i this is what i
would try to do but
um
i also think if these are standardized
numbers
you should also support those numerical
codes
oh yeah we do how i mean where does it
say that
uh that's unfortunately the
the exam the third line in the table
where it's to
the ncbi index foreign we don't give
these as examples right we don't give
examples that's not how documentation
works
okay i misunderstood i will fix this
okay all right all right all right okay
this functionality is great by the way
i'm just
you know we're dealing with details here
but i just the details drive me crazy
okay biosequence modified what does it
do
this is for handling uh operations that
really can't be described fully as
string operations that have some
biological
detail such as dropping in complete
codons
moving to a start codon dropping from a
stop letter
things that are defined yeah that's
those are useful things
but is modify just like we have molecule
modify
is that really the right kind of way to
describe is modify the right kind of
thing because this is a sequence to
sequence transformation
i guess it's right i mean i guess that's
consistent with what we're doing with
molecule which is a molecule to molecule
transformation
i'd say that's right
um
ah okay look i think michael has to go
i'd like to comment on some things on
the live stream but but if michael needs
to go he should he should drop
um i think we'll go ahead and dropped
yeah okay
um all right so
this isn't right either this is not
right okay
let's let's go back here all right
generate a list of instances in which
wildcards are
tired
is random instance giving
based on wild cards yes because it
wasn't for wild cards random instances
would give same same same same
you see what i'm saying okay
not sure why then we if we have if we
have a biosequence
if we have biosequence instances why do
we need random instance right isn't that
just
knowing them different no because
because this is can be very long
biosequence instances could be very you
know if you say nnn
n means anything right
okay
give me another famous wild card
s-s
okay
um
what the hell is sorry i'm sorry what
does it mean unicode characters why are
we counting unicode characters
they're just ascii right
for the extended sequence types it's
really handy for
um transfer rna for folks to use
um kind of greek letters and such things
so what oh yeah i mean yeah
it's that's a detail right sure
actually we what we would have to do
to be consistent
this is what we
that's what we should do just like we do
for geo
you
master have a dilemma there
what the heck is com computation here
no generate all subsequences of a given
sequence is that right
oh yeah that's better but is it all in
fact or is it
no
did it write the specified subsequences
well you know it's sufficient to say all
because that gives the idea of what's
going on
oh my gosh ali is saying there are
exceptions even in the vertebrate
mitochondrial code
okay all right but let's i'm sorry let's
keep going with this
um
i'm looking up here and i'm concerned
the bio
where's string match queue
find positions of sub strings
find positions of sub strings
you
you
okay
um where's that ones
let's see start codons
are you sure that are we going to have
more things than biosequence modifier is
it actually in the end going to be only
about codons and
stops start codons and things like that
yeah this is going to be our primary way
to modify secondary structure
okay
um
what
what that's not true there are proteins
whose physiological function is not
known
aren't there i mean why would it
necessarily be known
that's that that that's a great point
yeah
okay but all the i mean the entities
that we have right those are
yeah biological sequence entities
and we we probably have proteins that
still extend beyond that so okay all
right scent it is
um known
human and other
genes
known human and other proteins
is it the alphabet or is it what's the
type
it's is it is is the type an alphabet i
hardly think so
the type includes all the letters that
are allowed
all of the degeneracy rules don't say
alphabets
um yeah i was going to say i don't
understand that title
okay so hold on hold on uh
biosequence entities
um
this is basically telling you base
biological
organisms or something
um
what are those things called i mean in
um
well this is basically genetic code
information
and then codes alphabets maybe
but it isn't just genetic is biosequence
type
yeah it's genes it's proteins okay
um
okay what is this dna rna
peptide dot dot right
that's right
okay
okay all right
what else here okay i'm gonna need to go
in a minute here so
um let me just uh
read through our comments on a live
stream
ali is commenting are we going to have a
session on red mine issues i certainly
hope so
i asked for one um
bug tracker marks some critical issues
as resolved when they clearly have not
been well
i've asked for such a session so i'm
hoping it's gonna happen
soon um maybe somebody who's
an organizing person here can um can
tell me when that's gonna happen
i could go look on my calendar and see
whether it's scheduled here
um
well i don't know where it is
um
[Music]
yeah i don't know where it is why isn't
it scheduled i don't know
i don't think i need to send a message i
don't think there's anybody
well maybe brady but i don't think
there's anybody here who can answer that
question
um i can't speak to the point i mean i
don't know specifically which
issues ali is referring to but i think
in
general we mark things as resolved when
they're fixed in our internal build
which may not necessarily mean
right it's actually in the download you
see
right okay brian is commenting
circulation
acid forms are used in lab to amplify
nucleic acids standard mrna
is only a viral rna can be circular yes
indeed
right if you use a strand displacing
polymerase it can bump
off the existing preceding copy
okay so he's suggesting
an option permit circular read through
okay we need some more biology
information here i you know what i have
heard of this phenomenon
of um use a strand displacing polymerase
it can bump off the existing preceding
copy
okay so we better go find out about that
that's going to inform where the string
take
boy well that that there's a question
where the string cake can do this
circular thing which probably it should
but there's a question of whether this
needs to
i don't think you can like generate a
you know a long
repeating sequence this way um
question from ethan what's the future of
this does i do drug discovery
you're planning to work on machine
learning potentials docking http
screening that's probably more of a json
question i don't know the answer i mean
i know
we have a whole bunch of things coming
in the area of um
uh additional molecular geometry kinds
of things
um ethan is saying i need
access to small molecule databases uh
which i
think kind of have a small molecule
database i don't really have as big a
small molecule database it depends
whether that's proprietary databases
so on potential ligands steered
molecular dynamics and so on
um i mean we have we have the the
chemical entities but there's also
very easy access to pubchem which is the
largest
uh small molecule data database
but i don't know the the bindings
compute binding free energy from
molecular dynamics
i mean we are just starting to work on
molecular dynamics kinds of things
um
uh ali is asking were there
bioinformatics people involved yes there
absolutely were bioinformatics people
involved in this design in fact
the fact there aren't any probably there
aren't any today because
because we're down to sort of the end of
the line
we think we are
um ethan was commenting that some stuff
in biosequences out of lexicographic
order
should look at that if we wanted unless
graphic order it's not completely clear
what it is
um ethan is commenting by version 13 we
should be able to net train on standard
data sets for learning protein structure
yes we would like to i don't know what
the status of these
things i mean i don't know what the
status of of uh
net encoders and so on for biosequences
can anybody comment on that
it's not bad our you know our friend
muhammad
has some good work here okay have you
been talking to him
very very sparsely until we can get the
basics off the ground but this
will be a good time to circle back okay
fine
i noticed you just moved to a new
university with a much fancier position
so all good there
um
okay uh let's see
valerie now i'm showing off the fact
that i can just about translate cyrillic
here
um they're even assuming i didn't get
that wrong i apologize if i did
there are even dna parts that could
encode multiple proteins or even
multiple rnas simultaneously
wait a minute this is different reading
frame type things and where
i'm somewhat confused by that
[Music]
she might be referring to the case of uh
selena cystine
and pyrocine which depending on
chemicals that are
kind of around the environment it
changes the way that the translation is
interpreted
there's an example that we have in
translate
of modifying one of the translation
tables to capture these effects
okay all right i i have to go i think
we're basically done here
um i wouldn't mind seeing this one last
time but
this is looking good that's a wonderful
functionality
great is is there anything we should
expose or leave it all futurized until
no no no
no make everything put everything out
there
but please fix the actual documentation
stylistic issues and so on
absolutely okay sounds good all right
thanks to folks here thanks to guys on
live